learning new details this morning about
a lethal and widespread outbreak of
Legionnaires disease one person has died
and possibly dozens have become ill from
the bacteria which can cause a severe
form of pneumonia all were guests at the
Sheraton Atlanta hotel mark Strassmann
is outside the hotel as the first
lawsuit is set to be filed today mark
good morning good morning this hotel is
still closed as it has been since
mid-july when everyone had to be
evacuated since then at least a dozen
people have tested positive for
Legionnaires but hundreds more may have
been exposed by the time guests arrived
at the Sheraton Atlanta on July 15th 49
year-old cameo Garrett was already dead
an autopsy showed she had coronary
issues and Legionnaires disease Garrett
went to a conference at the Sheraton a
week before she died Germany Greer did
too I couldn't sleep didn't want to eat
couldn't drink cuz everything was
horrible I was delirious did you know
your own name I got to the point where I
didn't
Greer's a 67 year old photographer he
was hired to document the same hotel
conference his fever hit 104.5 Atlanta's
Piedmont Hospital kept him for four days
the doctor said we have had two other
cases already before yours Legionnaires
disease is a severe form of pneumonia
people get sick inhaling microscopic
water droplets containing the Legionella
bacteria it is not contagious this is
one of those bugs that lives out in the
environment amongst us and on occasion
it gets into a man-made water system
contaminates it and it can be very hard
to get rid of when that happens the CDC
says one in ten Legionnaires victims
will die Georgia Health officials are
now investigating 75 Legionnaire cases
12 confirmed and 63 probable all of them
were Sheraton Atlanta guests in a
statement the hotel offered its deepest
sympathies to all those affected adding
a thorough cleaning of the hotel's
entire water distribution system has
been completed including scrubbing and
chlorine
apologies won't do it in this situation
attorney Chris Stewart represents 40
Sheraton guests with confirmed or
presumptive cases of Legionnaires he
says other guests scattered around the
country may also have the disease this
is a massive problem nationwide people
don't know they're sick yet with
Legionnaires disease I mean literally we
get a new client every single day it's a
potential population of exposed people
is in the hundreds the Sheraton Atlanta
says it won't reopen until test results
show the threat is over Germany Greer
six five weeks says he's still only 65
percent healthy this is Twilight Zone
this is completely different than
anything I've ever experienced in my
life
health officials looking at when people
may have been exposed here are looking
at a time line that lasts more than a
month Anthony this hotel will remain
closed at least through this Wednesday
so scary how easily that spread mark
thank you